this is my life now all i do now is
is like have my own technical problems
and go
i i'm sorry in a
it's a complete silence yeah
that's exactly it i think we need like
we can add i.t tech
to a lot of our resumes and stuff right
yeah i
am not good at it and i continue to not
be good at it
never hire people at least you're
consistent
and i feel like that's there's that
there's that
very reliably bad at it i'm exactly the
same so this works
um i'm really excited to get a chance to
speak with you there is no shortage of
things certainly to talk about but first
um this friday you will be part of
another south by southwest
this is not your first time at the
festival um
what do you love about this audience and
what keeps bringing you back
well you know we were supposed to
actually i mean i was supposed to
be at south by southwest last year so
like this exact week i was supposed to
fly to austin and do south by and i just
remember the week
ticking by and they didn't cancel it and
i was like
am i really getting on a plane at the
end of this week
to go talk in texas um so actually
to be honest i'm just excited to be able
to have the conversation that i
tried to have a year ago like that feels
nice continuity feels
nice it's good to put it on the map
great conversations
that's exciting well this year fans
won't only see you but they will see you
with the hilarious amber ruffin
late night girls club and that sounds
like a very good time
what can people expect from you and
amber we had a great you know what she
is great and we just had such a fun
conversation and
i had lots of technical problems during
conversation
which i think is like it really spoke to
our pandemic filming situation like i
i tried a different room i was like let
me mix it up let me go in a different
room and then the sun was changing so
there are
moments in the interview where the sun
is coming directly into my and then i'm
like
moving all around the room but we just
keep talking
so it actually was a very rollicking
conversation and honestly
she's terrific and it just was like so
nice to talk to someone who has
kind of the same job as me there's not a
lot of people to talk to
and um i mean she launched her show
during the pandemics so that's like a
whole other
level of conversation what topics are
you guys hitting on
oh well that's i mean we talked about
the pandemic a lot and we talked about
our
goals for our shows and we talked about
the path to get there and
and we talked about the world at large
it's a very roving
conversation it's a real lark if i may
say
okay you may say so it's now in 2021
yeah there are not many late night girls
no
so what the heck like honestly what what
is it going to take to get more women
in late night i know i don't i wish that
i had
i wish the problem we can stay up late
a lot of the time we've got kids we're
awake people have menopause they stay
awake like
people are up we just tapped into the
hot flash market
it would be like which is like middle of
the night cold sweats
let's let's watch tv instead grab your
ice pack
get the ice pack take your pajama top
off and just just like a bunch of
topless pajama-less women
i think you have something there i don't
know why there aren't more of us there
should be more there
have you know great great great women
and great shows have come and gone
uh since i've been on the air and uh of
course
i want more women in late night i want
this
do you think it's because there's more
male executives up at the top making the
decision for women or do you like what
do you
or is it the numbers or what do you
think it is like i actually haven't
i literally have no idea i'm so sorry i
had this
i wish that i had the special uh the
special insider
scoop for you but actually i really
don't know i don't know
i don't know the mysteries of why shows
come and go when i think that they
should stay on like
i was amazed when michelle wolf's show
left our airwaves i was like what you're
not even gonna
i will say this i do think that it's
like very
algorithm driven our current kind of the
tv model and so
it's it's actually really much harder to
give a show
time to find its legs it's there's
it's a less generous environment to let
a show
kind of find itself and with a show like
this
you do find yourself you do have to like
drop into it and go all right let me
feel this out a little bit it's a much
different type of
show to create like a scripted show
where you film it all at once
so yeah no definitely that makes sense
you posted on twitter that it has been
one year since you filmed full frontal
with samantha bee in studio
that's a long time what do you miss most
about being in studio i mean i know for
us it's the energy
it's the vibe it's right all the things
it's not dogs running through the set
you know i know we now have a different
studio space so we're back in
a studio it's a different studio than we
used to have so we don't have an
audience it's a much smaller tighter
experience which was really by design
because
we just needed to be able to control our
environment more like
yeah previously we were in a studio that
we shared with
like six other shows and i just didn't
think that that was practical or
possible for the future so now we're
kind of a hybrid you know we're
mostly back in the studio i still film
stuff at home
when appropriate and i'm trying very
gently to go out into the field a little
bit now
um i'm still not vaccinated so and
most of the people i work with are not
vaccinated so we have to be very careful
when we're tested all the time it's like
a whole
situation i'm dying to get back out
there like just to get on a
plane and go film an interview in
another place
yeah oh it's so delicious just to go
across the canadian border
i know right now
oh boy we can have you in our studio at
et canada when we're allowed back and we
could do this in person
oh oh you're making oh you're making my
day
i want to do it so badly i know me too
we're going to make it happen we're
going to do it or we'll get there for
sure yeah we will
um you're into your sixth season of full
frontal with samantha bee six seasons
already
of his critically acclaimed show i know
you're not one to bite your tongue you
have
beautiful opinions where does the
strength for that come from because
it can be very scary you know in
any time to speak your mind and say what
say what you think
um i don't think you know it's
i i just when i started the show i felt
like i had nothing left to lose like i
felt like
if i didn't say it now i wouldn't have a
chance again so
i've just i treat every show as as
though it were
the last you know in a way i treat every
show like it's the last show i go
well why not i mean
i don't i don't think it takes anything
i don't think it takes a special
constitution or anything
i do think it takes the discipline of
not caring that much what other people
think
and that is something that i think hard
with age it's really hard it actually is
really hard and it's a lifelong journey
to not
just kind of to to not shape yourself
around other people's opinions of you
is very hard it's really hard for women
especially
for women that's one thing it really is
it really truly is a lifelong journey it
took me a really long time to get to
that place and
even at that place where i feel like i'm
most
fully myself i still don't read anything
about myself online
because i don't i feel like it just gets
into your psyche so i just
i forgot everything i think that's a
good idea
no i think that's a really good idea um
et canada loves a good take on something
so i have to ask you what
is your take on the oprah interview with
megan and harry
no hot it was
really intense it was
very good very delicious some real
stones were
unturned i thought it was really great i
thought it was great
i wasn't in a lesson in interviewing 101
i missed that 4 30 time slot with oprah
wasn't that remember back in the day of
course
oh my gosh i really i really do
miss oprah and it's so funny because i
feel like
in a weird way because her show's been
off for quite a while now i feel like
another generation has just gone like
who's this oprah
she seems terrific like no she's the
best
and she's been doing it forever of
course this interview was great
yeah no by how candid how open meghan
markle was i really
i really admired it i thought it was
really good listen
lay it out yeah for sure so 2020 was a
pivotal year in regards to politics the
us
was very divided and really still is
so be honest not having trump on twitter
is doing what to your life it has
improved my life so
tremendously it has been
it has just cleared out so much space up
here
so much space up top brushed off the
cobwebs i do think the world is a better
place without him on twitter
i do i think it was like it was you know
not
hard to adjust to i don't want to sound
like it was difficult it was just so
weird you know it's almost like i'm
liking it to acclimatizing to
a different elevation do you know what i
mean like the instant that he was
de-platformed
a lot of fog just kind of cleared for
all of us and i
definitely spent a couple of days in a
fugue state where i just wasn't
exactly as mad all the time and that's
been really nice
definitely i do think we would be in
much worse shape right now
if he was still on twitter i he really
impacted a lot of people with his
terrible terrible thoughts and words
so it is very nice that he is you have
done so many things
so many wonderful things i mean from the
voice work to the shows
um i know another book is being worked
on
what else do you want to do like let's
put it in the universe what's the plan
what do we do manifest what do we have
here interesting well i do love
my job i love what i'm doing i am
i would say two-thirds of a way through
a book uh
that i'm also very proud of i'd like to
write another book
after that i have good idea for a book
and then
um after that you know i have
a production um i'm a production company
we have
super exciting projects coming down the
pike that i'm really proud of that i
totally can't talk about
so come on you can't be all right but
then when you come to et canada to do
the interview you're going to tell us
everything
i'll tell you everything you'll be first
you'll be okay
you'll be the first to know i'm making
that promise
i love it okay i do think that being
behind the scenes as a producer of other
people's shows is really exciting to me
um that i really want to do in addition
to
uh in addition to hosting my show which
i continue to love to do
and also i'm raising bees and i'm really
getting into it so i'm excited for the
spring
when um my hives can get back up and
running again
i love that you raise bees well we love
you so much you're so wonderful
and uh just love watching what you're
doing it's so inspiring
thank you thank you so much and i'm just
so glad that i could
i got this working really quite frankly
i'm really glad too
you know what this actually in the end
this is much smoother than
my own i.t performance at south by
southwest
you just have to trust me on that okay
you